welcome to this video see ba-bam 12 okay
a Vienna I game which g3 okay that's not
a bad line very unhealthy set up going
with a 66 is kind of set up at some very
reliable let's say home yeah it should
be six maybe yeah what is he doing you
really want to go F for here okay
yeah Bishop f4 Nigeria check simple
simple but crude but sometimes root is
effective um you so I can take only 3
now why not the question is what is this
kind of position each formed some move
or not I think it is right sorry g-form
Bishop g4 should be playable I mean
playable wrong word i think it's just
good right look f6 bishop you two wins
and this looks really bad I've got got
each form also in the mix or i can take
which is not bad I guess winning a ton
of pawns still wonder cycle each form I
think taking first this is better right
if I go Queen g5 now is soon probably
not Queen g5 adds a self pin self pins
are right self pins are often not a
really good idea
h3 Bishop f3 is there something there
cam just taking now I probably could
have done that could have done that
quicker but anyway hmm Jim hard to say
that's a really really tough position
yeah I definitely want to Castle here so
this is why I went queen age for quickly
try to to get my king out of it it's
there it's there some attack that I can
go from g5g five SS a move hmm yeah I
guess I hope rook g1 Queen f2 is
possible I guess so root g one is not a
not an issue and I'm threatening g-form
right f6 summer looks wrong yes still
this wins material right the bishop is
strapped
check so trying to get this counter play
going yeah okay it's just a pawn right
don't want to rock this seven look f8
this all looks very passive so not doing
that
Luke f7 king bed it's really just one
check and then it's it should be over
well that looks that looks wrong really
91 maybe i'm just taking here come on
Knight takes rook edge a distance is
completely winning and I'm threatening
age two
h2 or yeah maybe H to come check yeah
the exchange up in the end game so that
is quite good night age three not sure
yet not sure yet how to do it okay
probably have to do that switch back to
whoopsie too hmm well we can go away for
a 5 which is protecting most things
check
check here snow move right
knight c6 okay i know i can go here
immediately
yeah yeah I probably I mean probably is
wrong I certainly had some had some
quicker way to do it but I mean okay it
is a loss I just wouldn't be formed yeah
I think I think this is just good right
I mean this this thing here he has to do
something else him there should be three
this leads to troll he cannot allow me
to take but um after g4 takes it is
really just bad for white check yeah
this is all all engine I mean but I what
I'm trying to say is them I played the
first line of our stock for sure till
this point and black is just better I
mean I shouldn't win as quickly as i did
I mean after this this B form g5 yeah g5
I had some doubts about the move because
it was really weakening the light square
then the computer is giving a good move
here 93 you're just wrong I didn't
consider the move simply also because
well the nitrous on d5 which is not
exactly bad but he's retreating it puts
to better squares g4s interestingly
enough a good move check attending this
with an attack interesting the idea what
lectures winds g four wins apiece I
played it wrongly no really I didn't
play it yes possible way but certainly a
way that was okay rook c8 is stronger
yeah probably okay yeah that rook rook
f8 was a bit stupid lost lost time but
the problem is though that this is not
coordinated and I'm going to win one
more porn so that it's not just an extra
exchange with porn and exchange which is
really too much
yeah okay i hope you enjoyed this thanks
for watching